year two post tom brady quarterback
depth chart for now is cam newton jared
stidham
robert kraft addressed that critical
position during his comments yesterday
here he is
we have a situation where we have
you know at this point in time um
we're trying to do what the best thing
for us is
you know i think in fairness to cam
i'm not sure he had the proper weapons
around him last year and then he got
covered and there were a lot of things
that happened and
i don't know that jared has ever really
gotten a fair shot so
we we have to wait and see what happens
and
this isn't something where you get
algebraic formulas
uh think of all the personnel wizards
who passed for six
rounds on tom brady and so one way or
another we have to
get that position solidified
he's absolutely right about that too and
i'm glad he mentioned the kova
reality with cam newton that's not an
excuse it's a fact
once he got covered number one he wasn't
available for a key game against the
kansas city chiefs that i feel like they
could have won
definitely with just slightly better
quarterback play and they didn't get it
from brian hoyer
and jared stidham but secondly that
threw
the the operation off killed her it did
and it felt like it was off-kilter for
the rest of the year cam newton wasn't
the same guy that he was before
it slowed down his development his
transition his learning of the offense
and those factors will not be at play as
they go into year two with cam newton so
i i i think he's accurate and again
that's not an excuse it's a fact chris
i i agreed mike i know it's it's a lot
of people don't want to hear that and
you know it's a lot of new england fans
in a lot of ways that don't want to hear
that
uh the the circumstances could not
have been tougher than what they were
last year
for really the patriots and for cam
newton especially
i mean you know rhythm is real as an
athlete
you know momentum is real i mean i sound
like i'm ray lewis remember he used to
go
momentum is real but but it is
you know you have positives to build off
of oh we're playing good i'm doing this
good
i feel in rhythm i'm going to continue
to get better here within the offense
and now i feel good you know
physically so we can keep this rolling
oh wait
now i can't practice i gotta lock myself
in a hotel room for two weeks
i can't throw a football and i was just
getting to a point where
i felt somewhat comfortable within the
offense
yeah i mean that it is real i mean
there's no doubt about that
and then of course we talked about
heartbreaking losses to go along with it
they're just they're not that far off
that's where
you know i i i try to talk to my new
england fans for the most part or my
friends that are like that to go you can
win with cam newton
yeah i know he's not your future but you
could go to the playoffs and make a real
playoff run with cam newton and be
dangerous in the afc
and i think they they are with the way
their team set up right now i think it
fits them better this year of course
than it did last year with some of the
weapons they got
craft was asked do you expect to be a
contender this year this was the last
question he took he said i expect to be
a contender
every year that's my objective last year
was very disappointing and i really do
believe that cam getting coveted and
what it did to the team it changed
a lot when we were in a good place yeah
now we'll have a chance to see i want
and
then that's that's it they get a chance
this year covet is behind them it
hopefully it's behind all of us by the
time september rolls around and it won't
be a factor
for any team's performance losing a key
player
having your facility shut down those
won't determine
who wins and loses who's good and who
isn't and
that would whatever you want to call it
excuse fact or somewhere in between
that's off the table this year for the
new england patriots and if they fail
it's going to be for reasons other than
they're starting quarterback cove
i agreed i just think cam newton's going
to be on a mission
i think the coaching staff will be on a
mission you could tell that
free agency the front office is on a
mission
you know that's a place that's just
they're they're not going to settle for
seven to nine i could tell you that
and they were like like you said just to
piggyback that they were two and one
and we were going wow they look pretty
good you know what they beat the raiders
by 16 points at home you're going all
right
and then cam hit and then they were two
and five
i mean right when that was all said and
done and yeah it was a battle ever
from you know since that point on and uh
yeah i just think
now that they know their quarterback and
it's here early spring
they know the players that they're gonna
have around the quarterback
with that offensive line and now you
give josh mcdaniels the whole offseason
here
to really toy and tinker with the
offense and now he knows what cam newton
is as a person
a learner how much he can throw on him
within the offense and things like that
i think this is where you see them
concoct the right formula
and he opens some eyes next year i
really would be shocked if cam newton
didn't open some eyes and play some good
football next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports